the family how's everything going oh
great man couldn't be better life is uh
is fantastic yeah
i like life man you do really oh my god
people are complaining about it first of
all you're lucky you're lucky enough to
be alive when you think about it you
know i'm saying your mother had to have
sex with your father
that your grandparents had to have sex
grand great-grandparents you got to have
sex it's lucky you're alive my god it's
amazing and i'm so happy every day
because i'm alive because it's just a
fluke there's so many
many more people that never got to be
alive
and that's an interesting point i guess
you're right
if you do the math so when people carve
about it i'm like man it's the greatest
gig in the world being live
you get to
eat at denny's wear a hat whatever you
want yeah yeah get haircuts
you've admitted that you're lazy i think
you've read six books in your life i've
read six six what kind of a woman would
be attracted to you do you think
well i have a lot of money
[Applause]
i came in and he was supposed to be the
uh
my uh kind of my guide through snl and
it turned out that
he is a [ __ ] stir
i'm not gonna guide any lady through
comedy that would take me uh first of
all i'd have to figure out how a lady
could do comment
wow one time i was watching one of those
i was wack yeah so i'm lagging off
watching it
and
all of a sudden bruce bomb is on it you
know that comedian
he's a comedian that's like a friend of
mine right
so he shows up like because he's the
comic part of it like they're showing
some sex all of a sudden he comes in and
right at the time when i was uh you know
finishing off yeah
so now i don't want to call up bruce
bond anymore
if
when this airs we're going to make sure
we get a picture of bruce bomb the flash
he's a great man he's a funny great man
but you need to see the visual to
understand
norm's pain yeah he does something and
then we have to guess what he's doing
and okay it's an activity
[Applause]
no i didn't expect this
i apologize
you can't do that man i'm rolling dice
oh seven oh well in all fairness
there's this movie coming out yes title
undetermined at this point chairman of
the board
oh
all right do something with that
i i bet the board is spelled b-o-r-e-d
oh my hey
this is 11 30.
this is 11 30. this isn't so much
playing
pinball
what's pinball
oh i see it
oh he's playing kendall
are you drunk
because all you did was ride a cooler
and you're sweating
i am well it's no it's hot is it
it's hotter than a two dollar well it's
got like 12 layers on it yeah i thought
it was going to be really cold
from canada this should be like it
should be springtime no i know i'm from
canada but you know i'm still a human
being
it's not like you revolve differently
[Laughter]
i'm from the frozen north yeah yeah it
gets colder than uh
it gets colder than that oh here we go
get your finger on the panic button no
it gets colder than a vampire's demeanor
wow
now norm i remember
years ago you told me that you were
there for the birth of your son and i
always remember and you said that was
the most exciting thing you had ever
participated in you remember that yes
yes and then what happened i took
crystal meth
let's talk about you now let me ask you
something another guy from canada has
come and invaded show business here in
the united states
so many funny guys come out of canada
what is it about canada that produces
all these comedians what do you think it
is um i don't know because when i'm in
canada no one's funny
do you think it's the long dark cold
winters you just had to find something
to laugh we don't have dark winters we
don't live in the arctic circle
but they're long aren't they they're
long and cold and they're cold and
really cold yeah they're cold
so when you're a kid up and i want to
put too fine a point on it but they're
cold yeah
yeah they fired no they didn't fire yet
no i'm serious i i talked to a guy that
said i'm fired
fired from your television job from on
the weekend that you know i do the news
the weekend update and i do the jokes
sometimes many times the best part of
the show yeah
it's all a matter of opinion that's your
opinion it's my opinion you know but
then the guys that can fire me that's
not their opinion now why would they
fire you well uh who fired you first of
all let's get some names here let's get
this on the record well i don't know the
guys like because the guys i work with
like lauren michaels and seth did lauren
michaels fire you no he did he didn't
fire me he likes me and stuff well he is
his show isn't it
yeah i thought it was his show yeah but
well then how can a guy come in from the
outside and fire you somebody from abc
fired you no no their nbc what happens
is your work on the show and then
there's these guys that hang out like in
the halls yeah we got them here we go we
got them here and they're called
executives they're mdc executives right
and then i'd see them i didn't know who
the hell they were what they did you
know
now i know what they do they fire me
from weekend update but
uh they
they they said that this guy don olmeyer
turns out to be the president yeah now i
know don olmeier and just between you
and me as an idiot
[Applause]
so i wouldn't take it seriously if this
guy fired you you may still have a job
you never know i'd wait for some
paperwork yeah i phoned him you know oh
you had the phone you had to phone in to
pick up your messages from that oh man
yeah so i said hey you don't know what
to say you're like hey how's it going
there you know you're trying to talk
about something else did you have a
turkey there for the thing or whatever
and then so he goes uh oh yeah i'm uh uh
i'm firing you there from the show and
then i i said uh
oh that's not good
and then i said why is that now and he
goes uh oh you're not you know you're
not funny yeah and then i said i said oh
lord that's even worse news you know
because no i don't got nothing to fall
back on
he's a good man he just fired you what
do you mean is it good what is wrong
with you you quizzling stop that
i don't know what quizzling means
hey
what what hey you said he used to play
this game with him
and this is it i have never seen him do
this
i mean this can only mean one thing i
think everyone do it do it again do it
again no this is not and that is filthy
right temperature for the baby
well how has it been since then well
it's been weird you know like uh
it's been weird because we're just fired
as it turned out right yeah they've uh
yeah i got fire and then
when i was talking to you on the show
that day because this guy don olmeyer
fired me and i didn't know the guy you
know and and you kept saying like he's
an idiot he's a pinhead you know and
stuff like that and i would say like
he's a good guy you know
and uh
turns out you were right
[Applause]
the setup of the joke is it's a jew joke
okay
two
um a gentile businessman meet on the
street one of them says how's business
the other one says great
see he gets it
he really got it he really liked it yeah
so the joke is about who doesn't get it
he's jewish he gets it you're not you
don't but i don't believe he got it oh
yeah he got it he got it can we find out
yeah yeah
why that's funny because it's two jews
and they're how's business great well
that's that's what he said no it's too
gentile businessman oh yeah that's
what's funny about it
i knew
i i don't honestly i i i mean he lost a
hat right yeah
and then you responded is it with a red
hat band yeah
i don't none of this makes any sense
it's a generational thing
[Applause]
i guess so
well
what is it
[Music]
now i will tell you what's cool about
the the internet and being internet
sensation stuff on the youtube now
everybody you know uh
uh i don't know if you remember about
but there's fame uh and did you ever
hear the andy williams quote in the
future everybody will be famous for 25
minutes yes i think it was andy warhol
ah
andy williams was moon river oh
and he was a generational
yeah okay
[Applause]
okay norm you're canadian yes i am so
what do you think of this whole
presidential mess uh well i hope that uh
uh the democrats don't steal the
election from
the winner you know but who knows
you like jordan bush i love george bush
man he's a good man decent you know none
of this
and he's uh you know he's not a
a lie or a crook murderer or anything
like that so it'd be good to get the
see i i don't i think we should get the
homicide out of the white house and get
like a a a fresh start because we don't
want any more murderers i think we
should just go on to the next question
oh clinton he murdered a guy yeah you
know what i don't know you know but i
have no accusations with that that's a
little too fast
let's just let's just go on to the next
book
yeah this is not my week what can i tell
you
oh it's not mine either i'm being very
nice okay
be a good boy
now norm do you never hear that no
we don't need no one to get into this
and i don't want to hear it and this is
not the place to make those accusations
and you're supposed to be funny
there you go
this is a live show
but you have been properly chastised by
barbara i'm not going to ask the next i
thought it was a matter of recording
okay let me do this okay
i'll tell you what's a matter of record
you will not be invited back if you
don't shut up all right
i i i won once time one time i kissed
relic
some beachcombers yeah were you on a
ferry or
no that uh indian guy from the show gave
me some bad heroin
that's not true
no that's you made that yeah
i did have a long kiss with relic
uh for a show or just uh
well party yeah no
i supposed to be on the beach comers
right that would have been awesome with
jackson davies too yeah yeah and uh
it turns out
i was never going to be on the beach
comers
and i was just going to be in relic's
hotel room
were you in vancouver yeah i was in
vancouver and i'm like this is going to
be the greatest i'm going to be as
supposed to be like the new breed of the
beachcomber and everything that's what
relic
so this is a next generation beach car
thing
the next generation relic was supposed
to be the executive producer and he'd
make occasional like uh appearances this
is what he told me in his hotel room
come on this didn't happen no i didn't
have it okay
i got to read this book uh sean uh i
should put that in there you should i
know there's a couple generations maybe
between you two as comedians looking at
a couple
watching norm over the years and some of
the characters what's it like being
alongside
one of the best oh it's great i mean i
love dirty work and i love saturday
night live and then i worked with norm
he was my boss my first boss in los
angeles yeah john's awesome man future
of comedy if you show uh this clip like
10 20 years from now you're gonna go
who's that old guy talking about who the
hell is relic
i'll
i
like relic and he'll be like me like 20
if when you look at this in the